ces plages seront bientôt vidées de
leurs touristes dès samedi l'accès au
bord de mer sera interdit pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de coronavirus les
bars et les restaurants seront fermés
une mesure prise par l'état de rio qui
est le deuxième foyer de contamination
du pays
le brésil est pour l'instant peu touchés
par le virus
le premier décès n'a eu lieu qu'en début
de semaine à sao paulo
nous devons encore renforcé les mesures
préventives surtout puisqu'il s'agit
d'une victime de la transmission
communautaire d'un dut un but tout comme
aux locales mais les mesures ont tardé à
être prises le précédent jaillard ball
sonar au fait partie des sceptiques
il estime qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence le
dirigeant de droite radicale a même
critiqué la décision prise par le
gouverneur de l'état de rio
l'économie allait bien mais ce virus a
provoqué une certaine hystérie
certains gouverneurs à mon avis même si
je me trompe peut-être ont pris des
mesures qui vont porter préjudice à
notre économie depuis mercredi une
partie de la population s'est mobilisée
contre son président avec comme méthode
un concert de casseroles aux fenêtres
[Musique]
je n'espère rien dessous gouvernement
parce qu'il ne néglige nous le peuple il
ne comprend pas la gravité du problème
il a minimisé les problèmes et
maintenant il est à la télévision en
portant masque mais il a dit des
absurdités encore et encore et les
gouvernements locaux ont commencé à
vraiment sentir qu'il disait des
absurdités et les citadins ne sont pas
les seuls à s'inquiéter dans les
communes reculées les peuples indigènes
se disent vulnérables après l'annoncé
d'un premier cas à manaus dans l'état
d'amazonie la plupart des bateaux qui
arrivent ici à même des produits de la
ville donc s'ils ne viennent plus ça va
être difficile de survivre là bas dans
les villes ils ont les ressources mais
ici on compte seulement sur dieu pour
prendre soin de nous des critiques qui
ont fini par faire fléchir la position
de jaillir bolton arrow vis-à-vis du
coronavirus les frontières brésiliennes
seront fermées dès lundi et pendant un
mois aux ressortissants européens
australiens et de certains pays d'asie
mais pas aux américains qui compte
pourtant plus de 10000 contaminés sur
leur sort
[Musique]